the country in utter chaos under joe
biden's leadership and the president
does not want to answer any of the tough
questions
may god protect our troops thank you
also very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
the white house getting called out for
putting biden in the presidential
witness protection program and things
are getting so bad that even the
left-wing associated press is knocking
biden for falling short on transparency
and avoiding important questions
in fact biden's done fewer news
conferences and interviews than the last
five presidents and it's not even close
biden has only held nine news
conferences since taking office compared
to trump's 22 and obama's 27. he is
outpacing the others with 200 and
informal q and a's when he's
relentlessly hounded by the media but
the white house says biden's always
eager to talk
he takes questions multiple times a week
his schedule has been quite packed but
he would like to do it hopefully we will
be able to add some local interviews in
the next couple of weeks the president's
taking your questions this president has
done 140 i don't even know maybe 150 by
now short q and a's where he takes
questions from the press typically a
couple times a week it's just not
accurate to suggest that he isn't
accessible or doesn't answer questions
all right so dana i don't like the way
they fudge these numbers on the count
these informal q and a's this is what
they count as an informal q a he leaves
marine one
he stops by someone goes how's buildback
better going he says it's going well
and then he walks away and that's
counted as one in formal q a so if you
take that out of there he's barely
talking to the press at all
well
if i could just start by saying we are
going to celebrate your news at the end
of the show so everyone stick around we
are thrilled for you and we're going to
have a chance to talk about it mr prime
time
so hell hath no uh fury like a dc media
scorned but their right to be
i mean they remember this is the uh
campaign the binding campaign promised a
return to normal and i have a feeling
that a lot of people in the press corps
don't think this is very normal
especially if you just look at those
numbers counting informal q as really
does feel like a cop-out however
there's a little bit of cost-benefit
analysis or risk assessment that seems
to be going on in the white house which
is is it better to put him out there to
take questions or not is it better to
have stories like this lead the five
that says he's not taking enough
questions rather than have him take
questions and cause perhaps additional
problems there's a calculation that you
have to make which is
why would we put the president out today
what message are we trying to deliver
can he seal the deal can he advance the
legislative agenda can he move joe
manchin by doing an interview in west
virginia etc and to me i think that
their answer is they ask all those
questions they do all those calculations
and they decide they'd much rather start
off the five with this story rather than
something else well katie doesn't he
have to create a story arc for his
presidency he has to do that himself
rhetorically no one's going to do it for
him and he's the most powerful man in
the world he's got to tell us what
his presidency is all about
well he has trouble defending his his
presidency he has trouble defending the
fact that democrats are at odds with his
agenda including moderate democrats when
he ran
as a moderate and he has a very
difficult time justifying what he's been
trying to push through congress or what
he's done
you know with executive orders through
the press and it's interesting
throughout his presidency for the last
year which is not typical jen sake the
press secretary often briefs on the same
day that joe biden gives a big speech or
does a press conference which is strange
you usually would allow the president's
words to stand for themselves but she's
always on standby to clean up or to
answer further questions or to clarify
maybe what the president meant if he
stumbles and doesn't say something
that's quite accurate which he has done
a number of times dana is absolutely
right this is all about risk and cost
benefit to him going out there and
saying something that jen sake that has
to clean up for an entire week we saw
this last summer when the infrastructure
bill and this big spending bill were you
know being debated for the first time
and joe biden said he wasn't going to
sign either one of them unless they came
together even though he had just
negotiated with republicans that they
would be separate bills and they spent
an entire week trying to clean that up
and paragraphs of a statement but when
it comes to the press here
i don't know what they expected this is
what joe biden did on the campaign trail
he was in his basement he never took
questions president trump held press
conferences for hours on end so long
that they ran out of questions and yet
they spent all their energy attacking
him instead of being grateful for the
access yeah greg they help elect the guy
and then they complain that the guy they
helped elect isn't talking to him enough
well that's part of that that's part of
their game right they have to look like
they are perturbed when they really are
remember how much stuff
how much stuff we learned under trump
whether we liked it or not
because he did everything in front of
you he was like those loud parents where
all the kids get to hear all the fights
and he was doing it in real time and it
wasn't just the press interviews every
day he was pulling back the curtain by
by asking by not just the press asking
him questions but he was asking
everybody else questions and that and so
so he literally was pulled not literally
figuratively pulling back the curtain
while joe well joe has the blinds drawn
and the curtains are closed and the
white house ends up as transparent as
like frosted mud
now if the because it's monday
and i want to do an analogy and it has
been a long time since i've done an
analogy
if the presidency were a car
donald trump would have been like a
convertible doorless dune buggy you know
you can see it all as it's going up and
down the dunes just like the banana
splits right but joe biden he's like a
black suv with illegal tinted windows
you can't see in but they can see out
and but the whole key is you're not
supposed to know who's actually driving
that suv
every day we knew who was driving that
dune buggy it was the crazy man with the
orange hair but this we don't know
what's going on we don't know who's in
control and they want to keep it that
way meanwhile joe's like the last
customer at a diner you know he's
oblivious to everybody waiting around
wanting to leave you know he's
there's there's inflation there's crime
there's school lockdowns and he's just
having the best time because he's
completely unaffected by these problems
he's in his ninth decade you know he's
just happy to have the soup yeah he's
like i'll have another cup of coffee yes
let's go all right harold who is driving
the tinidot suv
uh well first off congrats man um that's
a that's a heck of a metaphor that greg
used thank you uh with the cars there i
i i do know
that every president tries to manage
his coverage dana knows as well better
than anybody on this panel some have
been more successful than others
w had success reagan had success with
dever and baker and
i think as you as you as you think about
biden i think one of the things that
he's having the biggest challenge with i
think you and katie nailed it when you
said that others are defining his
presidency
he's letting others deliver the message
and deliver the message around his
message the presidency is really about
developing to your point jesse a
narrative a compelling one a constant
one changing and adjusting as as some of
the circumstances and some of the the
press may change your facts may change
around things but you have to have a
compelling vision for why you want to be
president your presidency should be
organized around it otherwise people
will define it for you take bill back
better all built back better was was a
big heap of money in the minds of people
who were really opposed to it people
really didn't understand what was in it
those who were against it defined it as
a big grab for climate change when in
fact there are other things there when
you poll separately or individually that
measure up and measure well with the
country so i think they should take from
learn from this understand he has 215 or
whatever that number was 216 informal q
and a's spent a little more time trying
to define the presidency define that
narrative and allow the president's
values and motives to come out as he's
as he's explaining and as he's defending
and trying to gather support within his
own party and obviously with
independents and republicans alike yeah
i think initially the narrative was that
he was going to beat the virus and then
he failed so what are we talking about
here
looks like gensake's the one driving the
trinidad suv hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else